[Music]
foreign
Glory
[Music]
foreign
hello hi
how are you how are you hello welcome to
uh this Hitman live stream this Casual
Friday live stream I've kind of referred
to bring it back bring it back
um hey everyone how's it going happy
Friday
welcome to Gamespot I'm John Luke this
is Jake hello uh this is
um uh very unprofessional stream uh not
to be confused with unprofessional
Fridays which is a giant bomb thing
um but uh yeah we we just threw a webcam
in here hooked up some microphones
hopefully we sound okay
uh let me know if there's any issues
with
um mics when you adjust audio I
literally threw this setup like an hour
ago but that's okay because today
we're playing some Hitman which is I'm
so freaking excited for this dude this
is very good I've played a couple hours
of it yesterday you haven't played at
all so I think we're gonna start with
you you will uh start by playing I think
maybe we trade off each contract I think
that might be a good way to go about it
yeah
uh so first off I see someone
um
in the chat uh the Youtube chat uh Yoshi
here is asking if this is a new game or
a new version of an older title okay um
game audio is kind of loud I will lower
that let's do that so
uh
basically Hitman 3 they have decided to
rename Hitman 3 into Hitman world of
assassination which includes every
single map from the modern Trilogy which
is like what 32 levels or something
exactly so they basically took all three
Hitman games and then said let's make it
one game which is excellent and then on
top of that
they added this new freelancer mode
which is a roguelite version of Hitman
and as a lot of people have been
describing it to me feels kind of almost
like a new game yes I it feels like a
new game I I mean obviously you're going
to the same locations but there is a
whole progression system based around
your safe house where you can upgrade it
and like furnish it and expand it
um one of the weird things is that you
don't actually have a bathroom right
away you have to unlock the bathroom
what yeah you'll see when we get there
interesting they're like 47 you can't
you can't [__] until you go kill someone
my people
of course there's a lot of like typical
assassinations like it'll choose a
random Target at a level and be like
okay you gotta find this person but once
you've killed everyone in a specific set
of uh
in a contract yeah yeah you'll get a
special Mission and you'll have to tail
people and you'll have to find people
that match the specific description it's
cool it feels like
it feels like uh i o interactive like
had this idea and then just ran with it
like ran with it as far as they could
and came up with this incredible mode
I'm a good what uh uh took over a year I
mean I think I announced this shortly
after the game came out and they delayed
it at one point the game didn't come out
until 2021. yeah it came out January
2021. so wait it's like two years later
man this game's very two years old Jesus
but it was worth it
uh epic Gaming says I still miss ghost
mode was that the multiplayer mode
because that's kind of cool that was the
multiplayer mode for two yeah I remember
playing that with you a little bit it
was cool it was pretty janky it was
janky and it was like kind of
undercooked but it had some neat ideas
yeah I remember it was like it came out
in beta
and then I don't think it ever yeah
unbated
oh yeah yeah do whatever you need to do
I'm gonna Lean Forward because um that's
how I game anyway if when it's my turn I
will lean forward okay okay okay
so I should check my welcome messages
obviously
because
oh boy this is really going to test my
knowledge with these Maps huh it really
does because you get one shot at this I
mean they're like elusive targets each
one where like all right if you fail you
just get kicked out of the mission other
thing is if you fail like one of the
lower priority ones uh it'll you won't
end your run
um you'll be able to give it another
shot however
targets will be on alert so whenever you
do one after that the targets will be
ready for you
sounds good so my strategy so far is I
I will always abort my campaign if I
[__] up uh one of the early
missions
just because they're usually pretty
quick but yeah here's your hideout okay
you walk around I have one gun you have
one gun and uh I lost it on my very
first mission took it out and then I
didn't get a gun okay I haven't had a
gun since my quick refresh of the
controls up is to put intake out downers
to drop but here it'll automatically
just rack it interesting
all right good to know
and then uh there's a shooting range but
you don't have that unlocked yet oh man
yeah so you can kind of walk around
there's let me in there's a bunch of
stuff that you just don't have access to
wow um but but the stuff you unlock here
isn't tied to
um I mean it is tied to your campaign
but you don't it doesn't reset if you oh
okay cool cool so it is just tied to you
leveling up your freelancer career and
whether you win or lose you'll get
experience I think there's like 100
Levels so there's
plenty there
it's here
so I'm just exploring now I have a
little bed uh someone wants to know if
you can do this on the hardest setting I
don't know I know there are ways to make
it tougher though
gameplay let's see
let's see I play with Instinct soft so
that'll be fun yeah I usually do that as
well uh I don't say anything for
difficulty um there are modifiers that
you can do that will make it harder
though
Vault oh
all these things I can unlock
wardrobe
so there's an upstairs area too I'm
pretty sure
finish Mission start
finish tutorial oh okay I should do the
tutorial first
yes well you just go right to that then
so these so these are your campaigns and
it'll tell you it'll give you details on
them and it'll tell you which locations
you're going to
okay interesting enforcer Market Guru oh
what's the B
order of the echo crime syndicate
strong natural resources driven by
greedy exploitation corrupt political
agendas
okay and I have to go to Dartmoor
Hokkaido and New York so you get to pick
which order you want to do it the thing
to keep in mind is that whichever one
you save for last is going to be the
final tougher one so you kind of want to
play it
you want to play it smart right like
Hokkaido is kind of a tough one Hokkaido
is a tough one
um let's see
and then the other thing too is that you
don't you spawn at any starting location
so like when I did this last night I did
a Hokkaido one and I spawned uh in the
lab without any uh I had like stuff my
way out of it oh my gosh
so it can be kind of brutal um tuna
this is like a good mix of like easy and
tough ones too yeah Colorado
okay I don't know if there's a way to
reset it like maybe just yeah
this one looks like a good one yeah
let's do this one I don't remember New
York New York's the bank right I think
New York is the bank I oh I actually did
not play New York that much I didn't
play much either
um let's see other options yeah let's go
let's go with that one
all right
okay well Paris obviously is the one I'm
the most familiar with so then you might
want to say Paris for last if you're
most familiar with that just because
that final mission will be the toughest
okay my final mission in this set like
obviously yeah I'll start with India
and see India is also a good one to do
um it looks like there are early I found
because there are so many people in
India uh on the India level and since
your final targets are just kind of
randomly selected it can be pretty tough
to you know silently kill them
so I don't have a silencer it seems like
no
it says unsilence pistol kill okay then
I'm fine
except that'll be kind of tough It's a
data of poison dart okay all right
let's see how this goes
okay okay
we go next mission don't forget
um yeah I see some chatting here if you
own Hitman 3 this is a free update if
you don't have Hitman 3A yeah I think
you have to buy Hitman or Hitman world
of assassination I actually don't know
how it works now that
is it just if you buy Hitman 3 you get
all the maps but if you have hit and one
and two you don't have access to I don't
know I don't know because I already had
Hitman 3 with all the maps for the other
ones unlocked so I'm not one two and
then I got three so yeah so I I'm
unfortunately not too clear on it
I mean it's good that they finally kind
of liked it made it one thing because
that has always been the worst part
about Hitman is like how confusing that
purchasing stuff has been and making
people rebuy stuff multiple times that
it's a great game but that stuff's
always sucked
okay
bring out gear
all right here we are spawn in a uh okay
unauthorized area which is good cool
excellent
alrighty here I'm gonna get our little
bit
on our end okay let's see so I gotta
eliminate one person
and I write this is a very complex map
that's what I remember
um so the couriers
um are where you can buy new weapons
good so they're just like characters or
suppliers I don't know actually what
couriers do I think should we go check
them out kill them you get some
currency
and then there's safes that you can uh
they're those safes that have or like
supply drops that have uh free items
that you can grab like people have three
items
okay obviously those guys are like
you're not gonna be cool with me
yeah in case you forgot on this mission
in particular
um through the markets there's soldiers
who are looking for you so you have to
blend in the Crowd Oh yes
oh boy it's not that much of an issue
because there's so many people jammed in
but um all right they say carriers uh
carrying money
so they do I just don't know how to get
the money from them like I think maybe
you're supposed to kill them and then
you can take it but I've never tried I
supplier deployed in the area I don't
want to blow my cover you know yeah okay
so I could talk to this guy I don't
think I have much money though you've
got nothing in the top right corner
when you are
as
a sniper wow
okay well I can't get in there that's
all good to know
and then what's the oh Mary Kish is here
hi Mary hey Mary how's it going oh hello
Bob Bob Jones
oh boy what's this safe for
is that just I think there's I think
there's money in there should I try and
go there or yeah no no the safe is uh
yeah you can go there because you just
get free items oh and that's where the
target is anyway so why don't I just do
that I'd head to the safe
uh
right sushi-san says this mode is not
for the faint of heart
we'll see how I do it's been a hot
minute since I've played
can I cross this
Brit is there like electricity that'll
exact me
if I cross
I think you're fine okay
I don't remember oh no
how to get around these guys now
um
oh can I no
is it to the North is that where you
need to go
yeah so if we look at the map like oh
yeah okay you gotta just get right
around yeah maybe I could let's see
what's over here
uh yeah Mary this so this is a
permadeath mode
um it's basically
Hitman uh Hitman roguelite in a sense
where you just pick a campaign uh
there's three different Maps you have to
go to you have to eliminate a Target
which is determined at random and as you
do it you can you as you play through
you get currency but if you die you uh
lose everything you have on hand and you
I think lose half your money or
something like that all right we're
doing it
um
it was fun though I was playing it last
night it's it's very tense
less trial and error
um so it's definitely like
I know you've been playing a lot of
Hitman so you'd probably be okay but if
you were just now getting into Hitman I
would say I wouldn't start with this
because uh you kind of want to know the
maps a little yeah
nowhere nor certain items are too if you
want to do some of the uh oh yeah stuff
okay this is a pretty looking gutter
let's see
oh hopefully I can get back up and I
didn't just screw myself oh yes
easy I mean I'm in
oh you can probably knock this guy out
yeah
what button is that again X okay no on
Playstation Square I was playing on Xbox
go Google
come on buddy I don't get any coins do I
messed up let's go yeah you can check
his heart yeah that or you can uh
strangle him with it oh yeah
well because it is a fiber wire hold on
then yes
uh is there uh should I not try and is
there like a negative penalty to killing
them unless one of your challenges is
not to kill anyone I don't think there's
really any concern got it
uh my god dude turn around like in
theory too like see that unsigned pistol
kill since that's not for the Target you
could do that with a guard ah I don't
know if I oh there's oh [__] two guys
there oh [__]
oh
good thing I looked yeah yikes I was not
paying attention let's just keep going
it's funny because sometimes you'll your
target will just be like a random NPC in
a crowded area and it's like all right
well I guess I'm just
throwing a knife in your head and
running away as fast as I can
but this is a little more elaborate
and I think they're like in that
building yeah yeah you're gonna have to
get through the
oh there's so many of them too you got
plenty of brush though to hide it I do
yeah maybe I can kind of shimmy around
over here I wish I knew
like the items were on this map a little
better
um I mean I know where to find
oh
don't get that guy oh that's so risky oh
that's so risky
let's just try and keep moving forward
yeah yeah you got plenty of rush to hide
in
sick
all right we got a security camera too
oh what's over there
no
you're good you're good
oh my bad nope nope it was already gone
so bad
[Music]
okay okay
all right you're good you're good
take one of those guises that's the next
yep
take this guys we're good everything's
fine yeah everything no one saw well
they did well they saw but they're but
they're dead now so it's one of them
still alive well hold on I'm about to
change that
there you go
easy yup take the gun because you can
take that gun back with you I'm pretty
sure so you can add that to your wall
great
all right
easy exactly
okay cool
um
so you don't lose points I don't think
from walking in front of the camera but
I think you might be able to shimmy past
it yeah I would like to avoid it if
possible
okay these guys are cool oh no no
they're not they're not they're not
okay they just don't like me being in
there specifically because I'm a guard
yeah maybe you can walk around enter
from the other side
um
yeah good call maybe because that's
where the um the chest is too
cool
well he doesn't like me either
oh yeah
yeah all right he'll recognize me right
right yeah
okay
if you give them a wide enough birth you
should build yeah you can kind of or
yeah you could go around the other way
I joined and saw a non-target person got
killed immediately this would be fun to
watch oh a pipe oh perfect yeah there's
gonna be a lot of casualties uh
unplanned casualties I imagine
[Music]
okay so I'm obviously trespassing
you know this was here I didn't either
no I was playing this level I have never
been here before
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
this is so bad
oh this is so bad go downstairs oh
I'm out I don't know where I'd put the
body though
I'm gonna keep going
oh my god oh my god let's get to the
other side see if there's a pole on the
other side you can climb down
what if I could just like see the person
just shoot him from here oh and go down
here
oh we got it we got this
Target is a target move
I don't see it on the menu
did they I swear oh no no no oh they're
just on the other side of the building
yeah there's also a safe nearby yeah
it's right below you
um so would you be trespassing if you
were down below
I think so because those people they're
different okay seemed mad that I was
there
yeah okay so can you Vault over and go
into that train oh like right there
that's where yes down there is where the
47 there's a safe nearby you should be
able to hack the code by examining
nearby Clues using your camera that's
not going to help me at all uh you can
strangle people just I know I just need
to knock her out
I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna kill her that would be she
didn't
do anything wrong
okay we're good okay safe okay so the
I think oh I could be I could actually
disguise myself as her though well no I
don't think I could take her yeah I
don't know if you can but this
the safe you should be able to get into
you know that's probably useful
no I need a code Clues I see I haven't
done a safety oh what
where would I even find those I don't
know
oh boy let's get to Target though yeah
that's the target
man
okay yeah there I just gotta keep
getting over there I need to get a
disguise
and I definitely can't take
her disguise right I don't think so no
um definitely it's not giving me an
option
so Mr Hussein
we got brush we're good
welcome quite over well my bookkeeper
informs me that you've had yet another
child oh I can open this uh can we ask
is it a good time to hop in this
franchise yeah 100 Playa and this is the
best time because now you don't need to
like
worry about what games got what maps how
you're gonna get maps you can just get
Hitman world of assassinations got all
the maps it will give you so much value
like you will you'll be playing this for
hours and and I mean what I will say is
probably don't start with freelancer
mode oh definitely kind of talked about
it beforehand but if you do want some
math knowledge I would say yeah go
through the campaign
yeah campaign's excellent a lot of fun
all right should I all right this guy
gets like he wants to get fiber wired I
think he's talking to someone I don't
know well can I oh yeah
oh yeah
why is she confused I don't know
oh my God there's so many people no
I can't we send a man earlier today to
get a hold of the dealer but so far no
longer
what can I do
oh
my God I want them to understand can you
they will absolutely see me climb back
up
uh
I could come back up from over there on
those I could get on that
that might be the better call
I really need to get that specific uh
card uniform if I can there were some
guards patrolling oh I don't know if I
can get that guy I don't know if you
build the job
and try
Oh Hang yep you can sure can
okay all right you should be able to
knock out one of these guys right yeah I
think so
there is a lot of them you have to tie
it pretty well yeah and uh
okay nope
but obviously now he's going over there
no no he's gonna turn the other way I
can feel it he's turning the other way
I know but he didn't
now he's turning the other way though
okay this might be it this might be it
oh
yeah yeah
I don't know where you're gonna hide
that body if I can draw if I can drop it
right into the yeah yeah
no are you kidding me they found it
okay that's okay that's okay they can
find a body that's okay they may have
found the body but they don't know who
caused it
hey you're good now though you got free
reign here that's true I should go down
let's hop down while they're worried
about the body pop the target
and then we'll get out of here
I wonder who saw it didn't just seem
like a body fault
I thought I was being pretty good about
that one you thought you were too I
thought you were safe I thought I was
being pretty good you're good you don't
need it was only that other the other
guy who's suspicious behind you yeah I'm
just
sedative Dark Gun okay the only bonus we
can get is with an unsiloned kill
button if you shoot you're going to get
a bunch of witnesses yeah but it might
that's a thousand bucks that's a
thousand whatever
money it is so it might be worth it it
just pop them and then run
but it's up to you
uh
where are they yeah it's we normally
they show up on the mini map but
maybe your settings I might have turned
it off I should maybe go into myself
I should maybe
let's do reset to default I think I I
was making a little too tough for myself
yeah I was okay
now it's trying to be too cool
but you know what not right now
so are they in they're in the train car
it looks like
oh and by himself is that in yeah and he
doesn't even suspect you he's not alone
let's go you're gonna pop him with a gun
or you're gonna oh my God yeah let's do
it ready
yeah
okay run
Cindy oh on Simon's pistol where no it
was supposed to be with a pistol
oh no that's fine that's fine just get
out of here
cute
that was my bad I got I got caught up in
the moment didn't read it yeah the
chat's probably all you [__] idiots
oh I can get on this train
boom done oh that would have been so
good if we just didn't mess up that one
thing and the body the body thing too my
body was funny though the body was funny
ah all right
first one down
you didn't fail your first one and lose
your pistol like I did so yeah I didn't
however I didn't complete any of the
original missions
all right
so I get to pick the next one right you
get to pick the next one do you want to
trade off contracts or do you want to
trade off campaigns ooh maybe we'll do
like I'll do like a full campaign and
then we'll
excellent work back there 47. like the
full three yeah I'll do I'll do three
and then you'll do three although I
wouldn't want to mess it up you know if
you
I think I think maybe we trade off each
one and then oh yeah but open that
that's just free [__] you're gonna get
it oh cool oh I could only pick one oops
Yeah you only pick one well all right I
guess I have explosions now but I would
put some of those weapons away
um
you can just do was it down on the d-pad
or no
cool nice
um
do I actually want that well here let's
put everything away um but yeah since
each one gets progressively harder like
maybe we should trade off each contract
and then rather than just like because I
don't want to get us to the next one
and then die right away before you get
to try it because I it is it gets tough
right yeah so like I'll do three and
then you do three I'll you do one I do
one you do one okay so you'll you won't
do this one yeah all right yeah let's do
it let's do it uh just because I think
it's gonna get pretty tough
do you want to take this with you I'm
gonna take the pistol take whatever you
want
no I don't want to lose your pistol I'll
put it away
all right but you where do you want to
go I think we say we should say Paris
for last yeah that's the one I'm the
most familiar with and since you'll be
doing that one you're familiar with it
I'm not familiar with New York so this
might end poorly I'm not either it's
okay
let's see
hey I hope you're doing well hope you're
doing well too thanks for
thanks for tuning in
on this lovely Friday
it's casually playing submit man
I like that a little something the
loading screen of him just in the car
this
is
find them
too
of them
with this newspaper
can you follow any of the um
I don't know what are they called like
um points of interest like the different
leads that could like get you into
places could you be like pretend to do
the thing where you can pretend to be
people
worth investigating nearby I recommend
you experience that
so that is one of those caches
um
is this game available yet sure is uh
you can you can get it right now if you
already own Hitman 3
uh you just have to all right update
your game we're doing the classic here
oh good call
oh no I don't want you to
am I in the women's bathroom
is it just a shared bathroom
me get knocker out
I'm tempted to she ruined my plan
oh
I'm not gonna kill her I'm just gonna
knock her out oh God there's a guy in
the stall
oh someone else is coming in
oh that's not gonna help either oh
that's fine you can just leave
oh
well
okay okay we're good
that should come in here now
is the janitor
why is the area being in okay yeah yeah
perfect maintenance guy yes great
can I fit more people in here is there a
limit how many people yeah it's full
it's only two you'll have to do the
stall yeah you can do the stall huh yeah
what the hell what what the hell what's
going on
[Laughter]
come on
Perfect Isn't it out order one
so No One's Gonna Come looking for him
easy easy
nailed it
was there anything in there by the way
there was there was some stuff on the
yeah there's some stuff on the ground I
wasn't sure if
crowbar or anything useful
okay you have a pipe now
I've upgraded from the newspaper all
right I should probably put that pipe
away though
oh I don't know you're I guess you're
yeah yeah like Oh I'm a maintenance guy
yeah you of course you'd have a pipe
oh cool he's yeah you're good
how you doing
there it is
[Music]
explosive Napoleon Bonaparte probably or
a baseball baseball might be fun
clean blown apart
that's what it says this is really good
is that what you picked yeah great what
is it poison Target sedative dark don't
have any of that so normally those
caches poor guy
would have something kind of related to
that have something kind of religious oh
they kind of messed you up uh there are
more caches though so
oh that's that's one of them right there
oh easy
wow oh no crime noticed who
I don't know
you're in combat fear within this but no
who noticed you no maybe the noise
oh no
what happened what happened
I closed all the doors
oh boy
we're okay
you will need a new disguise though
oh you're right
well no one's coming in
yeah well hold on
I don't think you can take her disguise
hmm
okay this person's coming in
Fair disguised
they said it was around here when you
get in like close the doors and get him
okay well
yeah just just just just
okay
let's just get out of here
oh boy
okay
oh you just gotta get down that hallway
if he's upstairs oh so you do want to go
upstairs
okay
I think you already got caught on
security cameras
hmm am I on the right level now I am
yeah I got I got a ways to go yeah
um
through a lot of people well
the
that guy just went into the room on the
left if you can
a yes yes yes knock him out
all right he's wearing a song
we're back in it
should probably put the pipe away yeah I
think it's time
wait for again
all right
definitely be wary because some of these
people might try and recognize you but
oh oh nope not in there
oh that's where they are though
cause yeah you could explode you could
explode them I would throw that in and
then I'd have to leave is it
does it explode on contact right away I
don't know
well hold on oh no I was just let's see
what this guy does
maybe he uh that's true too long because
he was moving around before
oh yeah okay he moves
you might be okay
um
too late
all the security cameras but you could
put him in that chest but they'll see
you yeah
oh but there's people up here I I don't
feel like you won't be able to go in
here
you can't oh okay
I love apples
just a guy who loves apples here
nothing else to it why is your tie like
that this is supposed to speak in
Annapolis oh yeah okay it's a good point
okay that you definitely cannot follow
him
no you need a code for that
is that a bust okay what
on the person's desk and there's like a
bust you could pick up
hmm
he's moving again he might be coming
I think that hallway him by the stairs I
think will probably be my best bet yeah
what if you're trying to disable the
security camera over there
uh don't I need to find like the station
to do it I mean you can shoot it but you
don't have a silencer so yeah
we're gonna throw an Apple at it
try
looking good
oh no wait until of course this guy's
going downstairs
head back in yeah yeah head back in yup
oh wait what
we could follow him down this hallway
see where he goes
do that fascinating oh
fascinating
[Laughter]
just throw that Apple at him oh that
other guy's coming out
be careful
it looks like I can't throw the Apple at
ah bummer
it's so tempting to just like push him
off I know
hmm
that's right you know how crap this
whole building is Wireless now the
director hates seeing cable oh no no no
no no
shoot oh no oh no
everything's fine just go around
there we go
we're okay
you can't go in here
can you go in here
yeah okay cool
all right A lot of people around here
no this is a tough one
okay
nice okay he's back in this room now
should we just throw the explosives
should I just do that maybe they will
100 see it but
well hold on do we have an Exit Plan no
we should probably think about that
check the map
where's the nearest exit
oh there's one right around the corner
oh okay
well there you go man
oh blow it up
walk away
oh my God oh my God no
oh we need this
card
that's fine that's fine
no one knows it's us
I wish it was explosive earlier we
definitely could have just left it there
yeah
I have popped up in these cameras so
many times oh yeah it's fine
you have to you have to make a track
hey Mr man that's fine everyone seems
pretty chill considering I just set off
an explosive in this Bank
um
yeah down here
prefers to look over all of us
oh you got this
all right we're good we're good boom
we're out the front door
there we go bam
okay oh
the tile for the shoulder bothers my OCD
bedtime
all right once again we did not do
any of the side objectives yeah
I feel like they're pretty tough early
on
yeah you just don't have the gear for it
right
she's like Flawless no notes
foreign
I think the syringe yeah
and it's lethal too which is nice
all right do you bring anything else we
can now so
all right uh
enable hardcore mode oh my God
all right so this is the unique Mission
um so there are there's one person you
need to kill there's looks like four
possible suspects and we need to profile
them got it I'm way away from the mic
figure out which one is the one that we
need to uh uh kill okay
so we need to do some detective work
here
I like that that sounds cool
uh wait did I grab myself first or can I
book a flight you can book flight and
grab your stuff okay okay
we now know the location of The
Syndicate leave uh oh okay so this says
what so they are uh they have a Handover
meeting they like to read their foodie
they're wearing glasses they got a
necklace brown hair and earrings cool
okay so you get a new item like the
suspect camera and when you point that
at someone all of those descriptions
will show up
all right so let's bring the pistol with
us
um you could bring your SMG because
those illuminate three guards with an
SMG but you'll have to go loud and the
thing about going loud on these missions
is that if you're if
um you kill the wrong suspect and
someone sees the body you're the the
target will try to I don't want to risk
it and if the target this is the one
that counts too like if you die or the
target escapes your campaign ends yeah I
feel pretty good then
I don't want to risk it but I bet I mean
if you know Paris pretty well I bet we
can find a knife at least so we can get
it with a knife I mean yeah there's
probably one in the kitchen
uh someone asked in this progression I'm
allowed to go back and play previous
missions too
uh you there will be enough chance I
think that you'll come back to these
levels but I think it'll be different
um it's like a one shot you got one shot
to do it okay so is that one of the
potential those are two of the potential
ones got an interesting location man if
I had the sniper and I could just
immediately try and snipe them I mean so
like pull out your camera
okay to zoom in more
interesting good Target enjoys reading
and they see themselves as a foodie cool
that's all I have for you good quality
camera uh and most of all
I would like to introduce you to
something new that actually still
explain the camera it's a camera
um actually no don't hear you I don't
want time no it's okay this is an okay I
mean it is it is trespassing but um not
a lot of people at least yeah it should
be okay I've actually never been
specifically down here
hmm
I could definitely get one of these
guards pretty I could get this guy
pretty easily
okay
perfect
foreign
how's the roguelike mode been so far can
it compare to actual roguelike games
yeah I mean this
it
when they first announced this I figured
like oh that's a neat idea that they
might get some out of but they really
like cranked it up to a hundred there's
a lot to do in this mode I'm having a
great time plus it's free you know I
mean if you own the game it's free it's
our boy helmet Krueger
there he is
helmet's a good disguise to get because
he he's got access yeah you can get
anywhere
I wonder if I should just try and get
him you you may not need to I'd look to
see where the where those people are
they'll shove on the map right okay
uh giant mom read from twitch she's
coming oh my goodness
Lucy and Tam sent you all oh my gosh
thank you all for coming thank you I
think you guys were just watching this
is more Hitman I hope you all like
Hitman look at that uh crazy yeah
there might be a knife in there since
that's your objective but if not there's
a nice oh okay that's money oh okay I'll
take it it's a good amount of money
um so for context we're on the third
mission where we have to identify yeah
yeah so yeah you might be good to just
head into the party because I I bet
they're all yeah I mean
I could go get helmet though
I don't know should I get Helmet or
should I keep the it's up to you
um
I want to get helmet okay good helmet
okay
should I do it now oh I don't know
can you dump his body over yeah
going for it
quick quick quick okay
no no
my hubris
okay well the good thing is
if I can just get out of combat his
disguise I could potentially get back
into
maybe maybe no oh no this is bad I might
have screwed myself here
oh my goodness oh boy
we gotta go loud
damn
I messed up you messed up I messed up
I shouldn't have done it
how unfortunate rip appears that you ran
out of here all right Jeff well your
turn then all right
you got a suit at least I gotta see it
you got the gauze suit man
ah
that's cool though I man this is a I'm
I'm gonna play so much of this over the
weekend I just couldn't I know I'm gonna
play a ton of this
that was about attempt 47 Unfortunately
The Syndicate managed to go into hiding
knowing you I'm sure that you have new
ideas so had that not been that final
sort of one we would have been able to
keep going but because it was one of
those important ones I usually reset
anyway because especially like these
first missions I don't really think too
hard about I just go in there and oh but
we still get one of these
okay explosive tripwire flash phone
what's a flash phone yeah I I hit
inspect
interesting I think we gotta go to the
tripwire yeah let's do that
Colorado Dartmoor Miami Paris sapiens uh
a good one that's a pretty good one yeah
let's do that
but we just did Paris why don't we start
Sapienza or Miami I would say Miami
because Sapienza I know pretty well
Miami I know kind of well
um should we take any guns
so
not worth it on these early ones because
if we lose yeah
I lost that pistol I guess
how's everyone's Friday doing in the
chat
anyone gonna play this you think
and it's kind of crazy because it's like
you were talking about this the other
day where it's like out of nowhere you
have this you have Hi-Fi Rush uh Dead
Space remake came out today uh which we
both got to play a little early although
I already want to replay replay it in
like New Game Plus so like I feel like I
have so many games I want to play right
now
find the person and
oh maybe knock him out and he'll have
like some money I think don't you think
47 keep an eye on them they might be
carrying something new this is a great
level
yeah it is
okay eliminate cards even SMG no
Witnesses poison Target dart gun okay we
might be able to do no Witnesses but
sometimes it depends on the um
character that I have to go for
[Music]
no caffeine Brandon thanks for listening
to uh after Dark
that was a good one we had uh we had
Khalifa on yeah
that was a lot of fun
visit up yeah yeah went up uh went up a
few hours ago
all right
hey Emilio what up
my good buddy Emilio in the chat hello
welcome
no I'm gonna run over and play around
with the pirate technique this is a big
map this is a huge map
where do we know where they are what's
yeah they're on the other side I gotta
go through the parking garage I think to
get over there okay
so I think if you can go right there yep
this is Hitman 2 right yeah as the
the first big level on Hitman 2.
oh yeah you can get him
although I don't really know how
beneficial that is yeah I don't know if
we need we're gonna need it okay let's
keep going this way now ready to meet up
with Sierra Knox over them
jeez
okay
hey man you can knock him out
oh yeah yeah you're good you're good
all right
all right no Witnesses
are they in the medical area
they are
taking a camp though I think I think no
yeah you're good it's this person though
oh my goodness grab that medical tea I
guess
um
blend in
okay yeah let's see where he goes
that you won't be able to go there
oh she should be able to
be able to climb all right oh one
witness thought sits in hand yes
yeah hold on yeah go go here go around
go on the other side
I think you can shimmy in between yeah
is possible no matter
beat Maybe
no
now the key here is Tire management I
mean if you're not careful you can burn
these tires off after 10 laps it's a
huge deal to manage that in this heat
you got the tripwire
how does that work can you just throw
that at that I'm not sure
but I don't think it's going to get the
job done
wait here yeah yeah
yeah we gotta find something to kill him
with
let me just repeat some ground rules for
those of you
who endures
you've gotta cover as much pressure
oh okay okay okay now we're talking
where are you going buddy
yeah let me go to there
that's not gonna work
you could light that oh wait wait go go
go to that truck near you
uh turn around there's like a little
forklift or something uh it looks like
you could activate it can you is that
like a distraction
yes different guy though oh but but you
get them away though
that guy
's gonna yeah
is this his Loop he's just going around
in a circle I think so
I mean there's he stands on oil right
can I set this on fire I think so I'm
not sure with what though
how does the trip the lethal tripwire
work
it's an explosive item oh
and then they don't like you holding
that
but where would I put it he would cross
I know
no no no they're gonna yeah that's a
little too risky
oh so what does it like I don't know
let's throw it okay yeah I just don't
know how it works
oh no
it's fine
I'm just gonna run in there and kill him
yeah
howdy
nice exit right to your right right to
your right
uh paramedics you just need a key or
something well done 47. this will surely
be a blow to The Syndicate
you should get back all right messy but
you know it's the first one it's fine
all right
oh
[Laughter]
here's a guy with a wrench
never hurt anyone in my life
hello adoring fan are you the adoring
fan
foreign
hey I got an achievement
is that a new achievement did they add
new ones or was that just
for
because uh
I don't know
what would you say is your favorite
level
in Hitman
um
God I don't know I really like uh uh
Dartmoor Dartmoor is really good
dartmoore is really good
um
oh I like uh uh the Maldives one quite a
bit seriously that one's a fun one it's
the tropical one recuperation oh is that
the one that they added as DLC for two
yeah
um I mean sapienzas sapiens is a classic
Paris is also extremely good
probably
the poison
that one is only a sedative oh okay
that's okay because sometimes the the
bonus objective is to knock out with a
set of
foreign
hey it's Louie he says hi Jake in jail
poison Target sedative boom there we go
no combat no body sounds oh okay well
let's not get too crazy here
are you gonna be able to knock all that
out we'll see I mean at least it's not
like you need a specific item to kill
them yeah I guess I'll put away the
I don't wanna
yeah I'm not really interested in that
and then I don't have a pistol because
we lost it
did we oh because you brought it on I
brought it on the other one yeah
well hey it lasted longer than mine did
Haven island yes that's the the name of
the one oh you know what the Germany the
isn't it Berlin though the Rave the Rave
that is a good map an amazing map
I also really like the winery uh the
winery is very good too I forget the
name uh where it's where it is
somewhere yeah it's in Spain I think
yeah something like that
welcome oh wow just put me straight in
the front Cindy cool currently in the
area
hold on just gotta take them down
[Laughter]
I will never not do that
all right two people
one's right there one's on the second
third third floor wow
and the other one is way over there cool
that's interesting the actual real
targets are still here yeah
so that makes me think that that some of
the um story things are still a thing
because it would make sense you can use
them as an opportunity to get into areas
um
gray fox asked so does this version of
Hitman include everything from one two
and three
so yes I think now you can buy Hitman
world of assassination which includes
all
30 missions 20 something missions or
whatever
uh however if you already have one and
two I don't know how it works like I
wonder if I think you might just still
need to buy three I don't I don't know
don't leave at least buy something yeah
you'll have to buy something what it is
I'm not sure but in theory yes like you
can just buy Hitman world of
assassination it includes everything
yeah price I think that's the the whole
point is just to eliminate all that
weird
multi-tiered you know what am I buying
what am I getting nonsense so I the guy
on the first floor he's all the way over
there it's kind of a pain I'm thinking
about maybe going in the cellar and
getting like a
thing that way yeah
ooh it'll move eventually
um on the other side of the building too
there's a pretty easy way to get to the
top of get to the higher floors it's
just a pipe you can oh yes I don't know
what you're talking about but I think
you do need a like a catering uniform
there is a caterer who's at the edge of
the map as well like by where you start
who's by himself smoking oh I want to go
do that then
was right no I should really go look for
it man pays our wages he serves a decent
dream
he's like in the corner of it
what do you mean that's just a parking
lot why wouldn't I be able to go there
this is steam deck verified I actually
don't know
you know I think people have played it
on I know people who played on Steam
questions so see that that bottom yeah
over here more to yeah he's like over
there okay kind of by the exit in that
car got it
but you can knock him out and then you
can head in
to the to the closed off areas if you
want to go that route
I might do that
what
so he's like buy the cars to your left
he may not be there yet it may be that
guy at the
the gate kind of to the right I think
yeah he's like by
these cars I believe or maybe he's in
between those two trucks
yeah it could be that guy then yeah I
think he'll chat to them and then yeah
who goes over there
okay
that's some point we could wait a sec
yeah yeah okay okay cool so cool
where do I put the body though
that I don't know
I think I just left
it oh no that's not you know you look
around see if they oh we're dumpster
right there perfect
foreign
waking up in a disgusting dumpster naked
naked covered in flies and
who knows what else oh
are they still there they are cool so
yeah I know for a fact like
past this parking lot kind of like to
the back corner of this place there's a
pipe you can climb up and no one cares
whenever I do it great
um and I think that takes you all the
way up to the third floor and then you
can kind of like shimmy around if you
need to get to the second but I'm pretty
sure our guys on the third floor
yeah I want to see what's the deal with
this oh hello
oh yeah how do I get in there though
oh I see
what do you have for me
can you be sedative I know you've got to
set it up already huh
toy robot
Flash
knocking down anyone nearby that
actually sounds kind of cool
uh
okay
but I want to know what the deal is with
uh
can I go back here is this guard gonna
be like go back there
pipe right there I was able to climb up
no one gave a shot wow
oh and then that's the guy I need to
take out the other guy oh [__] how do
you oh yeah okay
um hmm
so there's him and then all the way up
there so might be by himself the guy out
top yeah there's like no one upstairs
except for some guards okay
um so if you want to do that first all
right I mean I don't know if you think
you can like
I just don't know how you're gonna do
with that other guy without yeah
nobody's being found no combat it's
gonna be rough like hmm
okay
all right I am trespassing now
can I
kind of shimmy I think you can oh wait
no maybe not
no I cannot
all right I will need to take out
someone in here then
not you
no
no this is actually not a great spot to
be in
[Music]
you just like drop a thing on him
um you could try
don't do it again
this is a terrible spot to be in yeah
try uh go back to the corner of this
little balcony and go down the pipe
maybe there's a way you can climb up no
I don't think there is
well I mean I could maybe try getting in
from like a second floor okay then I
would try going down on that pipe
because then you can shoot me along the
second floor yeah yeah good call
okay
what if we do
get there come on
there we go oh my gosh game what are you
doing
fair oh come on okay there it is
uh oh
calm down yeah you can jump jump and
then I think
I think you can climb through
I should be able to because I think
yeah there's like no one in this room
except for a guard that was on the
balcony so it should be pretty easy to
kill you just take his outfit
sure can
another gun you can take home to
away
guys
find a place to stash I think there's a
okay there's a thing covered way over
there oh my gosh I should be good but
all right now you might just be able to
walk up yeah I mean maybe I do think
this might be a different security guard
uniform than the other one on that floor
but we'll see
well at least you got access here
so I want
let's see yeah I think these guys are
gonna turn me away
yep
shoot my boss was like not even the
bodyguards come through here so I'm
really sorry buddy
um
I could try getting him there somehow
is there another maybe check that
balcony oh and see if maybe there's a
way
oh
it doesn't really show pipes on the map
over here nope
uh nope
um
any ideas
struggling to think here how to kind of
get up
hmm
foreign
I don't know if I want to risk that
again though
I mean you could go back to the um the
first guy got pipe that you climbed up
like because there's that one door that
you may have been able to get past those
guards yeah that might be the better oh
well I don't think you can take that
guys
okay whatever that guy
I can't tell I can't remember if they
show up things black on the mini map I
think it means you can't take there
no black
just means they're not alerted to you
okay I think
uh yeah what about out here is there a
well this is right below
the uh fire where you can set up the
fireworks
seem like it
oh maybe a distraction from on the
guards
all right I'm gonna try going for that
pipe again all right let's do it that's
definitely the best option we had
coin drop oh do I have coins no I don't
have any coins do I
hmm hmm
oh dude
and there's that other person no way no
way
the problem is I could like I just don't
think I can knock that guy out yeah ah
and what and also that guy over there
he's just like not moved at all yeah
he's not gonna move I don't know how
you're gonna get that guy without
hmm
I think you might just have to see if
you can get through that door
okay like could you open the door and
immediately go right it looks like
or no yeah okay
all right
is there a thing I can I need to find a
place to put his body yeah
I mean I could just shimmy it over there
right and just hope that no one finds it
yeah
probably
we're going for it
all right
okay
okay all right hopefully this guy's
gonna be a piece of cake now
hope so
what's up dude
okay okay
all right
oh
people recognize me
oh those are some guns you'll take back
with you though
well
it's
this person
oh man
this is a brutal one this is tough
good Lord
um remember too you got the sedative
I might want to use a sedative on him
yeah I think but I'll just see you just
stick a needle and know where to drag
him is the problem
and these two guys talking over here and
then I have
this guy over here
see
yeah I have no idea where you're gonna
Stow this body
hmm
okay well definitely not while he's
there
I mean this guy kind of doesn't move
so
I might be okay it's this guy
I think I'll maybe take him out and then
just wait for him to
like I don't know go back and chat with
that other guy or something maybe
okay next time he goes back over there
I'm gonna I'm gonna go for it
uh
whoa hold on it's not giving me the
option to do the sedative
weird
oh do you have to can you only stick it
in oh my God are you kidding me I
thought you could stick people maybe
stand behind one of the other guys see
I know they're both well I can they're
not worth it I think it's because he's
sitting down it's not letting me
dude are you kidding me
all right well hold on then
if that's the case
then I just need something else yeah
there's gotta be a sword or something up
here right you can just throw at him
dirt is a
it's not like a vampire costume up here
somewhere
oh wow
oh
you're Whispering I do that when I'm
playing a stealth game
I'll start whispering to myself
so I'm like I don't want to it's too
tense
gosh there's nothing here this is so
difficult
Murphy's Law he's lawn though yeah yeah
if anything that could go actually went
wrong
Bronx wouldn't even be here well there's
got to be something here I can use
because I can't even Nova thought
because that is correct now if you get
Hitman world of assassination it
includes one two and three all in one
package so you can just load up any of
the 30-something missions or
20-something missions I think there's 10
each game and then some DLC so I think
it is 30 something
word that Library
no I want to
if you're gonna if you're gonna fire off
a shot it's Gotta Be It's gotta be on
the guy yeah
but I was hoping you'd there'd be like a
sword or something you just throw I know
right
I oh wait what's that rat poison I can
put it in his in his stuff but he's
sitting right there he's gonna see you
maybe you can get away with it
his hands on it when his hand moves you
should be able to he just took a sip oh
you're waiting for that guy
okay he's putting it down
okay he's
gonna see he's gonna see it
okay I don't know what else to do
oh
I mean he's gonna know
I think I you gotta gotta make a
decision oh I know I know I'm wasting
time
hold on hold on
is that lethal yeah I could just throw a
screwdriver in
they'll see the body but at this point I
don't know yeah
okay we'll hold on I should actually
make sure I'm in a good spot to then
yeah maybe not with that guy right there
uh yes this is free if you already own
the game oh hold on hold on
wait that's the that's the guy right no
no it's not the guy but that's okay
but they're all distracted
oh he did get up he got up poison is it
this is this is it this is it oh my gosh
see if it lets you use okay you have to
use the rat poison that's fine
get away
possible design
all right where's the nearest bathroom
is that it
oh
God did we do it no it's just rat poison
though I know I know but I gotta follow
him yeah
yeah yeah drink it drink it
all right there it is
yep
oh not feeling so good huh
all right you're no longer trespassing
you're no one's suspicious okay
okay where'd he go to the right okay
yeah yes perfect yes uh should I
non-lethal him yeah I've used the
sedative
all right now break his neck and now
kill him scissors too grab those
scissors
oh man my patience it paid off paid off
turns out we just need to turn off your
power okay
yeah that's that's fine
that's normal this is his vomit covered
wait no no no no I didn't want that
oh God
nice guy I'll just leave
um
so now we got to get that other guy
yeah I mean
that's a tough one
maybe we can throw something and uh
oh
that guy's suspicious of you not
trespassing you're suspicious yeah we're
good we're good
hmm
oh wow
um
he's over there
I could probably just go back down that
pipe right you should be able to
I mean you're gonna have to go up to the
third floor and then down oh you know
maybe I should just take the stairs that
might
be more normal yeah
all right man get off your freaking
phone
is it the guy with the yeah there's the
guy that's the guy with the foam
so I think I saw if you head back inside
was there a distraction in there
on here to like draw what was that right
there brake glass oh no that's break
glass I don't do that
I mean
what's even in there
can't tell
that would distract other cards not bad
probably
and then get in here
hmm
throwing ax at him it's true
I mean that might be what it's going to
come down to here yeah if I got it
like you could try throwing
the bust maybe to like get the other guy
with powder work
it just knocks them out
I think it'll get both of them I think
it will I I imagine
let's try that hold on
there's a couple cards yeah hmm
uh let's see I see my good on here right
yeah I think you I mean pretty much
anything under yeah I should be fine
because I just want to like [__] lure
him
okay well there's an accident too that's
good to know
try uh just try throwing something out
in the alley Maybe
oh just like to call sometimes you're
right out here like just throw the bus
down right at the door
yeah good good idea
oh
all right hopefully it's the guy we want
but he's not gonna come inside he's just
gonna stop there well even if it's not
the guy
it's not the guy but
maybe we get rid of this guy first
that's what I'm thinking yeah
oh no don't turn around don't turn
around
Oh I thought he was turning around I
thought so too
get in here
huh
oh okay we're good
all right you might be able to do this
nobody's found in no combat
okay so so how do we get him then what
else do you have what other equipment do
you have here oh I mean I have the I
could throw the scissors or the ax if we
want to get fun with it
um I just want to make sure that no one
sees it good down there if you knock him
out like the only one who had who could
have seen him before was okay
I'm going for it
oh wait you're just throwing it Oh I
thought you're gonna lure him down no no
no no I was okay drag him down
well done 47. this will surely be a blow
to The Syndicate
you should get back to the safe house
I'll contact you later
we got this
all right
there it is completed all the side
perfect run
all right
do you want to do then do you want to do
the next one since no I don't mess up
your run no no no no you should do it
all right
and then I think uh I think that'll
we'll probably stop after that yeah
that's probably a good good place
oh I love this game so much
let me know if I can be available
and you got a nice new gun
I got several guns uh a little pistol I
got my weird uh powder powder yeah
screwdrivers screwdrivers are handy
boom there you go perfect all right oh
so one strategy you can do too is like
if you complete like if you take out a
room perfectly no one's alerted yeah and
you've got money that's usually a good
time to go buy weapons because you know
you're not gonna lose them that makes
sense
but hopefully we leveled you up look at
that completed all of them let's go all
right
all right so when you level up your
freelancer Mastery that's when you get
some stuff I think man a hundred
you unlock the Wardrobe
increase gear capacity all right perfect
gate 47.
I think he only takes uh gates with the
47.
I'm just picturing like everything he
does in life has to be the number 47.
okay
I'm ready when you've prepped the next
assignment
should we take another syringe
yeah I'd say so oh actually can we see
what oh good call
foreign
Target sedative but that's in a medic so
but poison kale yeah yeah neither of
those will be helpful
but we might as well take something
here's what we'll do we're gonna take
the sedative but we're just gonna put it
away
we now have information on the city so
now you've got one banked
yeah do you want to bank all my other
stuff uh yeah
I've provided you with new Intel
all right you got a bank Dometic another
sedative we might be able to find a
sedative on the map though
I'm trying to think where there would be
one if if at all all right
Stakes are a bit higher I'm not going to
be hitting random people in the head
with uh
uh with wrenches so don't worry
welcome to sapiens that's a decent spot
to start yeah
however as we don't know the exact
description this means you will have to
do your own Recon to help you we have
the following information they are
attending a covert meeting we also know
that they have brown hair they are
wearing a necklace they are wearing
earrings and wearing a hat as to habits
and voices your target has a tendency to
enjoy food of any kind and last but not
least they have a sweet tooth I hope
this will help be careful 47 and most of
all good luck
okay
let's go for this guy because he or she
is right there
oh okay cool
so uh what was again
the Foodies necklace foodie hat brown
hair okay well they got the Hat they got
that's brown hair right
they have a necklace what's their secret
meeting they have earrings I can't tell
because the hair they do have earrings
I'm pretty sure I thought I saw
something
some of the towels fit the description
they do have a sweet tooth foodie
they are eating
they specifically ate something sweet
I can't see the ear yes wait yes hearing
yes okay earrings so this person has
almost everything we should just wait
for the meeting yeah yeah because what I
noticed when I was doing this before is
that usually everyone has like
everything except except for the one
okay
but like sometimes that one thing is
they just don't have a hat or something
so this might be like there might be
someone exactly like this who also has a
meeting and she just doesn't
oh she's heading in there that I'm
definitely can't follow him there huh uh
if you go back to where your apartment
was you can get on the roof and get in
there that way
yeah she's going
in all your time's doing it here too
that must just be a glitch then
no the other one's part of the costume
that was a glitch okay
is that her
yes
you can shimmy on that wall over there
and then I think inside here is like the
kitchen area and you can maybe become a
chef
[Music]
three people
oh oh hold on actually
I have an idea
um if you go back out to that apartment
area
um there's a guy who has a like Chef's
outfit you can take
okay
uh turn around actually if you I think
you can get up on that balcony right
there
uh from from the uh left
yeah on the bed
hey yep perfect all right
oh yeah he's playing Hitman
he's playing Hitman uh Sniper Challenge
[__]
was that her
looks like her yeah
where where
are you sure you went to the meeting she
could have yeah but she'll do it again
hi there
I mean I'll tell you what all right well
at least we can follow her now Mr cruso
is so out of it ah so you got demoted
huh
I wouldn't call it that I
guess I can while she's doing that I can
check out the other ones too oh here's
what I can do too when you go I can do
uh
click on write signatures Prime Suspect
oh that's cool so it's just and then we
can find the other ones and uh
where are the other ones
I mean I know we loved it but
two of them
ones out there oh the ruins that's an
awful place to be
I'm just gonna run through that
[Music]
all right be careful here this place
that sucks okay well we can she doesn't
have a hat okay so you can eliminate her
uh hat
necklace does have a necklace
seems like they potentially a brown hair
do they have an earring
sorry
no no maybe the other year
there could be a could be one earring
situation no
all right our girls looking more and
more likely yeah
yeah we got one other person we can
check
I hope it's her it'll be easy because we
can
I think
way over there interesting
it's not bad
we can get there
she is
if I wasn't a badass bodyguard let's see
okay they have a hat
they have a necklace she does not have
earrings though I don't think no
be careful
okay the other girl
there are also other assassins around so
if you're too like conspicuous oh are
there yeah
are they trying to also hunt the same
person they trying to hunt you oh
interesting
uh
uh I can hold the knife as a chef right
no one cares yeah I think so
I don't think we're gonna get the poison
kill
I don't know where you'd find poison
here on the map yeah
I
I don't know if you'll be able to you
can okay
yeah not in here
okay all right
so it's a good opportunity
a place to hide the body though
oh wait yeah there is
she gonna come back this way though
there as well but there's definitely
people here
there's a lookout nearby apparently
and so don't so don't do anything
suspicious
she's a foodie man
that's what it means to be a foodie you
just eat food
weird places yeah
even though you're you're a kitchen
assistant the way you're holding that
knife is this hell is suspicious
okay she goes through the same area uh
she's dead but she's not going to
be played safe and just wait yeah yeah I
think you're right
I want this clean
but we can follow her because she's
gonna go back out into the um
the town yeah I kind of want to see
where she goes
oh assassin nearby
foreign
like in most games that's what it would
be but in this it's just because he's an
assassin you know he'll just [__]
professional doesn't need it
what uh
not suspicious at all
perfectly normal
so she's just gonna go in that bathroom
area again I think so
interesting
hmm
do you mind you're really pissing me off
can you just leave me alone
I mean you can't do anything in the
bathroom there's people there right now
it's a little too crowded
it's a shame we can't find poison
because
she used to be so easy I just I just
don't know I'm sure there's poison on
this map I could not tell you I wonder
if there's some in the kitchen
because usually there is right like
that's usually that's rat poison not a
sedative yeah I mean the rat poison
would get her to run to a bathroom
I I don't think we'll come up
I don't know let's find out oh she's
going in a different way okay
huh
what is she doing
oh this is a good place to kill her I
think
this might work
well now it's not well now it's not
oh so close keep closing these doors
[Music]
oh that's the meeting
okay well now we know for sure I mean
a strange ad hoc jargon that they could
be trying to keep this meeting Secret
I would advise to investigate
if you had a sniper you could go like
run to the Tower and yeah and wait oh
that'd be cool
all right we've actually got a good
amount of money if we do this clean we
can stop by uh
fixer
okay if she goes back in the kitchen
you're good
go back in go back in
oh this is it
she goes through that door you're good
stab her
yeah oh we got her leader eliminated all
right
boom
clean
all right good job well done should we
exfil do you want to look at the uh well
what do we um at least buy some good
check check this yeah check the supplier
it'd be cool to get something rad for
next time
yeah they're uh
oh they're downstairs can I get in here
yeah here yeah you're good are you right
there uh other side
whoa that's a lot of cash damn really
close to getting the sniper yeah you
just want to wait
um
yeah it would be nice it's pretty cheap
though
just store it just in case you got a
mission yeah why don't you get one
sedative
all right let's get out of here you're
gonna get a pretty good payout on this
too heck yeah
all right nice ended with a W dude
this is super fun it's so good this is
really good yeah it's really good wow
oh my goodness
well anyway I think we're gonna call it
here yeah hey
I'm gonna hung out um thanks again to
Tam and Lucy for um
uh rating us for those who stuck around
really appreciated
um hopefully you all have this will make
any good time watching and hopefully
have a good Friday and uh yeah I think
we'll uh we'll hopefully see y'all next
week uh I'd like to do more of these
kinds of I'd play this again next yeah
yeah well I mean I'll definitely do this
again but in general it'd be cool to do
some more you got some rooms oh I did
what'd I get hold on uh we'll find out I
think after this screen and I'll tell
you what you got I want to see real
quick
foreign
motivational poster
interesting all right all right cool
anyway thanks everyone we'll see y'all
later and have a wonderful weekend